[Music]
well even as big tech continues to
conspire to suppress my documentary what
is a woman most recently with
eventbrite's decision to ban all
screening events and watch parties from
their platform still the ideas from the
film and the question the ultimate
question are out there nothing can be
done now to stop that in fact the left
is finally beginning to realize that
they must come up with some kind of
answer they can't dodge it forever
that's why today for our daily
cancellation i'm going to take a take a
look at two of the most recent attempts
to answer
and if not answer that at least uh
handle the great question of our time
what is a woman so we begin with a man
named matt ho who is um running for
senate in north carolina on the green
party platform matt was very proud of
himself a few days ago when he tweeted
this quote today i got my first what is
a woman question before i could say
anything my campaign manager replied f
off transphobe
there was no reason to say anything else
hashtag f off transphobe
trans rights are human rights
now as a green party candidate i must
admit it takes some guts to alienate 50
of your electoral base by cussing out
one person
still it's it's a rather sad thing to
see a grown man
proud of the fact that he had to dodge a
question that my three-year-old could
answer
perhaps next he'll brag about the time
when someone asked him whether the earth
is flat or round and he responded by
bursting into tears and running out of
the room
i mean these are moments of true courage
right
now i tried to explain to matt um that
eff off is not exactly a sufficient
answer to the question and it to his
credit he did give another attempt to
actually answer it
less to his credit his second attempt is
arguably even dumber than his first a
few hours later he tweeted this
for all the people demanding an answer
as to what is a woman
a woman is a person who identifies as an
adult female
trans rights are human rights
now look in a certain sense this is
progress
at least he's not attempting to define
the word woman by using the word woman
and yet this definition has its own very
significant problems because a female
person
is a human being who is of the nature to
bear offspring and who produces ova
which are female gametes or reproductive
cells
so if someone identifies as female than
they are they are identifying as a human
capable of bearing offspring and
producing ova
but
a male who identifies as producing ova
still cannot produce ova he produces
sperm which are male gametes no matter
how he feels
or what he says or how he identifies he
will produce male reproductive cells all
the same
therefore identifying as female when
you're male is no different in kind than
identifying as seven feet tall when
you're actually five and a half feet
tall
so what matt is claiming is is that
there is basically no difference
definitionally between an actual seven
foot tall human being and a human being
who's a foot and a half shorter but
views themselves as equal in height to
the seven foot person
but that's nonsense
i mean if it's true
that females are females
but then males could be females too
that means that females effectively
don't exist
and if they don't exist then it doesn't
make any sense to identify as one you
can only identify as that which can be
defined but if it can't be defined or
rather if it can be defined then there
must be a physical reality against which
your self-identification can be judged
accurate or inaccurate so if females
exist then males cannot be females and
if females do not exist then males also
cannot be females so no matter what you
do
males cannot be females
and matt hoe is left up a creek without
a paddle
and nobody is even sending a search
party for him because nobody will know
that he's missing because he's a green
party candidate it's a terrible
situation all around
but if a politician on twitter
can't solve the riddle
maybe somebody on tick tock can there's
a video going around recently gone viral
from a user called circus pork roast who
uh
i mean that's her username
who believes that she has finally once
and for all
come up with the answer to the dreaded
question let's listen
i keep seeing all these clips from the
matt walsh documentary what is a woman
where he asks these you know gender
studies experts what is a woman um and
then when they give him these like long
carefully thought out answers that like
delve into the identity and the
complexities of you know the label of
woman um he basically mocks them for not
being able to give him like a short
concise
biologically truthful answer if you've
watched any of these clips and you
yourself have wondered i don't
understand why they can't just give like
a simple answer like it's such a simple
question um i'm going to compare it to
something else and i'm going to ask you
this question what is a mother
can you tell me that in one sentence yes
i can thank you for asking mother is a
term that describes a woman's
relationship to her children
there you go that's what it means you
know you may think that uh
myself as a revered children's author
filmmaker documentarian
um
women's studies scholar that i would get
a lot of respect you know and that i
would feel respected but often i don't
because there's just one title that i've
been missing and if you've been missing
it too then you need established titles
established titles is your opportunity
to earn the title of lord or lady and
gain the respect that you so richly
deserve or at least i deserve so i
assume you do too all you need is a one
square foot plot of land in scotland
established titles is a project based on
a historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you'll be bestowed with at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate in edelston scotland
plus an official certificate which i
have right here proving that i am lord
matt walsh and it's got the crest and
everything that you need your
certificate feature is a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there's also a
couple packs that come with adjoining
plots of land for the special someone in
your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of lord
or lady to your credit cards your plane
tickets even your dating profiles most
importantly and get this established
titles told me that the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my
exclusive link will receive a plot
within a few walking minutes of mine
mines we can all gather there together
and stand on our one square foot of land
and uh just look at each other i guess
so depending on how many of you uh want
to become a lord or lady we can build
our own kingdom established titles is
actually running a massive sale right
now on top of this plus if you use the
code walsh you get an additional 10 off
so go to
establishtitles.comwalsh to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
hopefully we can all move on with our
lives now but i suspect that's not the
case
and you might say oh well obviously a
mother is someone who has given birth
and then raised children
um
but it's actually a lot more complicated
than that right um because yes there are
mothers who were pregnant and gave birth
to children and then raised those
children and we all agree those are
mothers but there's also people who
adopted children they didn't give birth
they were never pregnant but we still
consider them to be mothers because they
take on the societal role of mother and
they accept that as their role and then
there's also people who gave birth and
then gave those children up for adoption
and wanted nothing to do with them and
don't consider themselves to be mothers
um are those
mothers do we consider those mothers as
well and then there's also people who
uh
were pregnant but had a miscarriage they
consider themselves to be mothers
but there are certain people who argue
against that and say well no your baby
was never born and therefore you're not
a mother and then there are people who
raise their nieces and nephews or their
grandchildren as their own children they
consider themselves to be mothers even
though they are also ants or
grandmothers therefore taking on two
separate labels at once and both of
those things are true at the same time
and so as you can see a supposedly
simple question that seems to be rooted
in biological reality is actually much
more rooted in the societal roles that
people play and the labels that they
accept upon themselves and the same
thing is true of gender it's partially
rooted in biology but in our modern
times it's more so rooted in
the roles we play in society and the
labels we accept for ourselves
okay let's try our best to sort through
this first of all
nothing that you said there actually
makes the term mother confusing or
opaque as i already noted the word
mother describes a woman in relation to
her children a woman who gives birth to
offspring is a mother a woman who
conceives children who then tragically
die in utero is also a mother a woman
who adopts a child is a mother too
because that child once adopted is her
child what does it mean for him to be
her child well she's taking on the role
as his primary female caretaker she's
accepting a unique legal and moral
responsibility for and to the child she
is dedicating her life to him she's a
mother this is not confusing now
there is some nuance here sure a child
who is put up for adoption may end up
with in effect two mothers because the
woman who gave birth to him is a mother
in the biological sense while the woman
who adopts him is a mother in every
other sense
this is why we often distinguish in
those situations between mother and
biological mother
again it's not really confusing you only
want to make it seem confusing because
you think it helps you make something
else seem confusing too and that brings
us to the second point
even if i agree that the word mother is
somehow vague or ambiguous which i don't
that still wouldn't at all prove that
the word woman is vague or ambiguous
there are there are ideas and concepts
that are difficult and hard to define
that doesn't make all ideas and concepts
difficult and hard to define
you can't prove that one word has no
objective definition simply by asserting
that some other word has no objective
definition this is what they they do all
the time they say well you asked me to
identify to define woman can you
identify this other word
what does that have to do with this word
we're talking about
so because one word can't be defined
that means no word can be defined
it's especially absurd in this case when
the other word mother actually does have
an objective definition and everyone
knows what the word means
the reason why mother
has some extra complexity
is that it is a word which describes a
role and a relationship you're right
about that
but it's a role and relationships
specifically fulfilled by women
mother is a role that many women fill
but being a woman itself is not a role
or a relationship it is by definition a
physical biological identity
after all if mother is a role
and woman is a role
then who exactly is filling these roles
we can only say anything about mothers
at all if we first establish that women
exist and can be defined there are
plenty of other words that describe
roles that women play or relationships
they take part in sister aunt girlfriend
waitress actress etc all of these
are roles that a woman can play
but even if on the margins there is some
element of ambiguity in some of these
roles
the roles can only exist and we can only
talk about them if women exist first and
whatever ambiguity you can find in the
role does not at all even come close to
creating ambiguity around the concept of
womanhood itself
but all of this
could almost be put to the side
because here's the real question for you
whatever you think about
mothers
whatever you think about women
i ask you this
if a man
with no children who isn't even a
caretaker of children
like all he he sits at home all day
playing video games he doesn't he's not
even he's not even around children
if he stood up one day and declared that
he's a mother
would you accept that
self-identification as valid would you
say well i guess you're a mother too
in other words
if i agree that the word mother has some
complexity and nuance to it
does that mean that just anyone can
legitimately claim the title for
themselves does physical reality impose
no requirements at all on the person who
makes this claim
it may be difficult to wrap your arms
around all that the word mother
describes but does that mean that it
describes nothing
does the word have a complex meaning or
no meaning
you're wondering whether an aunt or a
grandmother who's very close to a child
counts as a mother
but would you wonder whether my
five-year-old son counts as a mother
i assume you would not so you may
struggle with the concept around the
margins yet you know that the word means
something and it therefore excludes
people lots of people actually
regardless of what they say about
themselves or what anyone else says
about them
and if you would agree that the word
mother cannot be applied to just anyone
then you must agree that the word woman
cannot be applied to just anyone
that there is a reality
that the word describes both in the case
of women and mothers
and women who are mothers
there's a reality that it describes
which means that someone can
make a claim
can identify themselves and be wrong
about it because it does not comport
with the reality that the words are
supposed to describe
that's the real point that you should be
thinking about
and you'll have plenty of time to think
about it because you are today
on this first flannel friday
canceled
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there